I swear I do not know where Met m life
is is at did you just end a sentence
with a preposition this one drives me
crazy and it's totally not a grammar
rule there are some good situations in
which you should still follow the rule
my name is William James and I am an
editor and English Professor based in
South Korea and I am going to be
reacting to Grammar Nazis this is like a
classic College Humor clip am I a
grammar Nazi I hope not a grammar Nazi
is someone who they're always corre
dirting your grammar to jump in and say
well actually especially in situations
when it's not really helpful to the
discussion you see grammar is very
important to the Nazi party I don't
really think I do that I am super super
interested in grammar and trying to get
to the bottom of not necessarily what's
right and wrong well I'm more interested
in good and bad rather than right and
wrong in the field it's known as
cognitive Linguistics when we try to
understand like what effect does this
you know sent structure or this pattern
in language have on the reader's mind
and if we arrange it differently is it
going to have a different effect on
their psychology on their ability to
process what we've written and I think
that kind of attention to the reader and
the reader psychology does give us a
stronger basis on which to say certain
things are not right and wrong because
as the descriptivist say languages are
evolving entities but it does give us
some foundation on which to to say this
sentence is better than that sentence so
I think that's kind of the background
that I come from so let's see if that
kind of analysis would be helpful for
this kind of video are you aware of any
Jews hiding in the
area no no I I assure you there haven't
been no Jews in this Village there
haven't been no Jews so there have been
some Jews oh uh sorry no I meant uh
there haven't been any juice no juice
here sorry I was confused by double
negative okay this first grammar rule is
definitely not a rule and actually I
think the singer Mick Jagger is going to
be really happy about this
one
get so this is known as the double
negative the man says there aren't no
Jews so are not and no Jews both of
those are carrying the negative
inflection and so people who say that
this is a mistake they argue that as a
matter of logic two negatives actually
make a positive so the man who's saying
there aren't no Jews according to these
people is actually saying there are some
Jews so the grammar Nazi or the
prescriptivists are going to argue that
you you can't say there aren't no Jews
you would have to say there aren't any
Jews but the fact is that both of these
phrases aren't no and aren't any they're
both double negatives or they're both as
much a double negative as each other the
only reason that there aren't any Jews
is considered correct and there aren't
no Jews is considered incorrect is that
in the 17th century in London the
dialect spoken there said aren't any
whereas in the more workingclass region
in northern England that dialect use
their aren't no and so of course the
dialect spoken in the north was seen as
uneducated unsophisticated by the people
in the south in London and that is where
the grammar books and the textbooks were
written so they just wrote The Textbook
to match their own local dialect if the
capital of England had been in the north
at the time then we would be arguing
about how aren't no is correct and
aren't any is incorrect they're both
double negatives and the only reason
we've chosen one over the other is by
complete historical accident there's
nothing more proper about AR no than
there is aren't any like it's not like
these are wrong but more generally you
can actually use double negatives to a
certain intentional effect fact we
generally use double negatives to avoid
the positive form of a statement so
let's say for example you watch this
YouTube video and somebody asks you how
it is you don't want to say that it was
boring because there's some interesting
aspect to it but at the same time it's
not like you're going to walk out and
say wow that was a really interesting
video so what you could say is well it
wasn't
uninteresting it was not uninteresting
and that is a double negative but it's a
way of saying saying there was a little
bit in there that was interesting the
double negative is a clever way of
avoiding the positive statement so
there's nothing ungrammatical about
double negatives it's just something
that these prescriptivists like to throw
out but they don't even really know the
history of where this rule came from and
so you can totally use it to different
effects are you familiar with one
shashana yes I know
her me and her buy our milk at the same
Market
me and her surely you meant to say she
and I
no yes of course this grammar rule is
real and it's a little bit tricky but
the funny thing about this rule is that
people who know the rule will actually
intentionally avoid it they'll they'll
break the rule on purpose because they
don't want to come off as a grammar Nazi
so the issue at stake here is some
confusion over the difference between
what's known as the nominative case and
the objective case basically the subject
and the object so the sentence is went
to the store and who went to the store
she and I went to the store she went to
the store I went to the store she and I
went to the store but let's take I out
of the subject position and move it over
to the object position of this uh
prepositional phrase she went to the
store with I not now because now the
pronoun is over in the prepositional
phrase phrase It's the object of a
preposition so she went to the store
with me the pronoun needs to express
whether the noun is functioning as the
subject or the object those are known as
the cases whether it's the nominative
case or the objective case the trick is
to take the other person out of the
sentence to see if it makes
sense me buy milk I think not I buy milk
you see and the grammar Nazi is right
what you can do is remove one of the
participants and see if the sentence
still makes sense so me went to the
store obviously is incorrect me is the
objective case but whenever it's the
subject we want the nominative case so
it would be I went to the store she went
to the store I went to the store with
her she went to the store with me I
swear I do not know where Met Life is is
that did you just send a sentence with a
preposition give Kel this one drives me
crazy and it's totally not a grammar
rule there are some good situations in
which you should still follow the rule
okay so the rule is it's supposed to be
you're not allowed to end a sentence
with a preposition and that's wrong
there's not a grammar rule saying that
you can't end a sentence with a
preposition the only reason that rule is
there is because whenever they were
trying to like codify English grammar to
write the first English grammar
textbooks in the 17th century these
Scholars were really enamored by Latin
and they thought that it should be a
model for English and in Latin there is
indeed a rule that you can't end a
sentence with a preposition it's
impossible like prepositions are fused
with words so like it's it's literally
impossible to end a sentence with a
preposition and so these Scholars wanted
that to be the rule for the English
language but that rule makes no sense
for English because Latin and English
are two different kinds of languages
Latin is a syn itic language and English
is an analytic language and what that
means is in Latin you express grammar by
changing changing the form of the verb
whereas English you change the grammar
by rearranging the word order so there's
nothing about the English language that
says you cannot end a sentence with a
preposition nothing at all this rule was
invented by an 18th century preacher
named lath I think his name was lath
father lath you know he he was really
interested in English grammar and he
would spend Pages arguing about why we
should be saying haath instead of has
he's the original grammar Nazi this is
the kind of person who invented this
Rule and it's totally bogus so there's
nothing at all about English grammar
that prevents you from ending a sentence
with a preposition so you can say
something like he is a person I have
great respect for and that's totally
fine it would be a lot stuffier to say
he is a person for whom I have great
respect obviously but in in formal
writing and especially in academic
writing I actually think it's a good
idea to follow this rule not because
father lth said you should but because
one it um it keeps the preposition tied
to its object the noun so you know
otherwise you would have this great
distance between them and it's nice to
keep things organized and keep them
together so it's not to say you can't
separate the preposition and its object
but I say it's a good idea in formal
writing okay but second all you know the
end of the sentence that's like Prime
real estate it it kind of has that
period at the end of the sentence or a
comma it it really has a kind of
emphasis so whatever comes right before
the end of a sentence that's going to
get a kind of oomph that I don't really
think you want to give to a preposition
if you keep the preposition tied to its
relative pronoun then you get it out of
the way and you get to end the sentence
with probably an adverb or the direct
object of the verb something that has
more substance to it an Open Class word
instead of a closed class word like like
a grammatical word like a preposition so
yeah I'm I'm going to side with the
Grammar Nazis on this one not because
they're right it's not a rule but I
think as a matter of style it is a good
uh thing to observe informal writing of
course when we're speaking it's totally
natural to end your sentences with the
preposition at the end but in writing
it's a little bit more reflective we
have more time to go through and edit
and rearrange our sentences and so I say
why not keep the preposition tied to its
relative pronoun and and don't end the
sentence with a closed class grammar
word instead give that Prime real estate
to something that's more uh important in
the context of your sentence when was
the last time you saw the
judeus about a month ago I was walking
by the river payon and I saw dfus
fishing so I went down to the river bank
to see if it was her but I couldn't get
a
confused did you really think I was so
stupid I wouldn't recognize a runon
sentence okay so this is a real thing a
runon sentence is when you try to join
two sentences together using only a
comma but here's the here's the funny
thing is like it's a matter of
punctuation it it basically happens when
people don't understand the difference
between a comma and a period they they
try to use a comma like a period so it
comes up in writing but it makes no
sense in the context of spoken language
the issue in writing is that the comma
has no grammatical power the the comma
if you look into the history of where
this punctuation comes from it actually
represents a pause in speaking so in the
earliest forms of writing you know not
many people could read and so a written
message would be read by one person to a
group of people who would listen to it
so let's say a message from the king or
something they would go down to the
square and read this message in the in
in the Public Square but you needed to
signal to this person when should you
take a breath so the comma kind of came
about in order to symbolize that pause
in speaking which we naturally take in
spoken language so yeah it it definitely
makes sense in the context of written
language a runon sentence is when you
try to join two or more independent
clauses using a comma but in spoken
language it makes no sense at all we
speak in runon sentences and I've
probably produced a few in this video
there was no Jews here Jew or Jews
plural plural wrong you have to match
your subject with your verb yeah so this
is definitely a rule it's called subject
verb agreement uh it's pretty basic for
native English speakers but English
Learners sometimes have difficulty with
this one and the basic idea is that
there is a difference between singular
nouns and plural nouns and the verb is
going to agree with that so we inflect
the verb for the subject if it's a
single subject singular verb and if it's
a plural subject than a plural verb but
it gets confusing whenever you have a
compound subject that is two singular
subjects joined by and in the subject
position so the rule is whenever you
have a compound subject then you would
use a plural plural verb because there
are two entities in the subject position
so let's use the verb go for example so
he goes she goes they go he and she go
we use the plural verb to match the
plural compound subject okay but let's
take it up a notch because then what if
the two or more entities in the subject
position refer to the same thing so
there's this famous book
wait so for example let's look at the
opening line of Vladimir nabokov's
Lolita Lolita light of my life fire of
my loins okay those are three entities
Lolita light of my life fire of my loins
and those three things are all referring
to the same person the same thing so in
that case we would use the singular verb
goes Lolita the light of my life the
fire of my loins
goes down the street I've heard from
numerous sources you are hiding
madus from
who from
whom who and whom yeah this is another
case of we've actually already gone over
this rule it's uh it's the same thing
who and whom that is the difference
between the nominative and objective
case it's the same thing when the
pronoun is the subject of the sentence
the nominative case we use who and
whenever the pronoun is the object of
the sentence it's in the objective case
we use whom M I have one more question
for you if you answer correctly I will
leave you and your family at peace if
not you are coming with
me now let's say you were writing a list
would would you or would you not put a
comma before the end it depends on
whether you are following the Chicago
Manual of style or the associated pres
guide oh the Oxford comma are we going
to do this we're going to talk about
this okay let's talk about it we'll make
this quick the Oxford comma is the comma
which comes in a list before the word
and before the the final item in that
list so I like apples cherries and
oranges the controversy is whether or
not there should be a comma before and
and oranges and like look in a lot of
cases okay you don't need it fine you
don't need it in many cases it's totally
redundant and you could just take it out
and not create any confusion there are
some cases in which leaving it out or
keeping it in creates some ambiguity
Benjamin dryer actually posted a great
example of this so like not including
the Oxford comma can definitely create
some confusion so here's his example of
it the highlights of his administration
include encounters with Rudy Giuliani a
healthc care disaster and a dildo
collector okay so look the the confusion
here is that are there three highlights
of his administration are those
highlights Rudy juliani a healthcare
disaster and a dildo collector or is
this sentence saying that Rudy Giuliani
is both a healthc care disaster and a
dildo collector you can't tell I think
use the Oxford comma there I said it
okay everybody's going to roast me for
this but I think it's I think it's good
to be consistent there are some
circumstances in which not having the
comma there will create confusion and
it's good to be consistent you don't
want to not be using the Oxford comma
over here and then all of a sudden have
a sentence with create some ambiguity
and then have to change your style like
you should be consistent in your usage
so if you're going to use the Oxford
comma sometimes use it all the time
that's what I think you can fight about
it all you want I don't care there's no
end to this debate so you know some
people understandably argue that you
don't need it if there is no ambiguity
but hey I'm I'm the writing teacher here
so I'm just going to stake my reputation
and say use the damn Oxford comma there
I said it hiding under the floorboards I
have finally found you
wait you are hiding under the
floorboards or is she a dangling
participle a dangling
[Music]
participant the dangling participle this
is what this is what finally took out
the grammar Nazi well it's
understandable this is actually a pretty
tricky uh grammatical rule um that you
know many people do break I actually
just saw a um on uh on Instagram
somebody broke this in a little video I
saw so basically a dangling participle
is a non-finite clause which is um
separated from the independent clause by
a comma and we call it dangling because
it's not attached to the syntax of the
rest of the sentence so imagine you had
like an independent clause which was um
like the birds flew high or higher the
birds flew higher and higher a
participle phrase could be watching from
the ground below now that participle
phrase which is going to be separated
from the main Clause by a comma that
participle phrase is going to modify the
thing that it's next to that's the thing
so like I guess you would think like I'm
the person who's watching the birds so
you could you would not it's a dangling
participle to say watching from the
ground below the birds flew higher and
higher cuz the birds weren't watching
the birds were flying I was watching so
watching from the the ground below I saw
the birds fly higher and higher that
would be okay but it's a it's known as a
dangling participle whenever a
participle phrase an ing phrase is
hanging off of the main Clause by a
comma but it's not actually attached to
the syntax of the rest of the sentence
so I think it's generally A good rule I
mean it's a good thing the Nazi killed
himself so let's keep dangling
participles uh it saved the day it saved
the movie so I really hope this shows
like grammar Nazis are generally what we
would consider these prescriptivists the
ones who were telling you what the rules
are and you know the dolly llama said
something one time he said learn the
rules so that you know how to break them
properly and I think that's I think
that's what we should go for here it's
it is important to know the rules not
because there are rules that you need to
follow blindly but you need to know the
structure that you're working with these
are as a writer these are your tools but
once you have a kind of deeper
understanding about these then you can
start to develop your own uses for them
and you can start to question these
rules like why is there this rule why
can't I end a sentence with a
preposition or split an infinitive who
says what's that rule all about and when
you really start to look into it you
find out it's not really a rule so learn
the rules so that you know how to break
them properly